a lot of theories about how the show was
gonna wrap up people are obsessed with
how it's gonna wrap up there are a lot
of strange theories out yeah what's the
strangest theory you've heard I'm not
gonna dismiss it because I want people
to watch the show but that ranges theory
I've heard is this DB cooper Theory DB
Cooper's a guy who jumped out of an
airplane in 1971 after getting $200,000
with a parachute with a parachute
because you know there was a lot of
hijackings then you know was it not
unusual to jump out of a plane and
people think that Don is going to you
know get Don is going to become him
because he actually looks like there's
all they have of DB Cooper is this
police sketch right and it looks a
little like it's a very handsome guy who
could McJob police sketches without
mustaches of white guys look like Johnny
he has a very you know cartoon favorable
features you know but I mean you know
people think it's gonna end in a plane
crash which Lionsgate would never pay
for budget you can probably figure out
what's not going to happen exactly this
is the budget of the show it won't go to
a comet hitting the euro Godzilla tax
New York and each Don Draper yeah jokes
at a sandwich they all have sandwiches
but they're very chocobo right but you
know you have been such a supporter of
the show for so long that I actually am
kind of breaking with my tradition and I
have actually brought a scene from the
end of the show the very end of the show
you brought a scene tonight yes I
brought a clip that I say okay guys I
feel like I want to put the theory to
rest and I also I feel like indebted to
you from supportive oh this is a real
honor that obviously a massive spoiler
but I guess I feel like I can't take it
and abhorrent I can't take people asked
let's show this this is the only tie
this is incredible scoop this clip from
the final episode
[Music]
you could see I mean it's still it's
bursting with period detail yeah
there's somewhat limited by budget
they're the only got nice touch to have
them put on his suicide hat but we did a
couple with the with a pad under the
watermelon because we only had one
watermelon
[Laughter]